phone last week after eight years
i threw away all the phones from rocky
died from maryland militant
we called it rocky it's one but 98
pounds
big tits and a big mouth
at first for the years i went on to do
with her started stalking me
i said what the hell are you doing at
this club i was like playing pool and
[ __ ]
i'll leave she said i'm stalking you
the hell are you talking about she said
that's what i'm doing
i said you want anything he said i like
a beer and a pack of spirits i
i'll go get it i get it for her and i go
back to playing pool and i come back i
should be gone
she was a triple little chick
you're a trippy kind of person free free
actually she was the freest person i
ever met
think besides myself i've always been
free spirit
don where did you grow up where you from
originally i was born in hortonville
wisconsin
and i'm in a closet
upstairs in the farmhouse for the first
five years in 1955.
well in 54 my mother's
husband got out of reformatory and and
two brothers to the girl he raped beat
him enough of lead pipes
my mother found him in bed dead so
my dad got out of the service real quick
that was scary
miles carpenter and uh
he got out of service took me out of the
closet
same month my grandmother died of a
broken heart they said
that was all she had she walks church
every morning gave all the money she
made every week to the church
my grandmother died a month after my dad
took me away from her
i still fear
i don't know why you were kept in the
closet for what five years
never had no shoes on never had no
clothes just a
smock why were you kept in the closet
secretly
if if junior carpenter would have found
out i was born
while he was in prison he had probably
killed my dad
junior carver was a farmer him and his
brother and dad they all owned their own
farms he was young
too and i was just a big secret
they called me tronzy and i asked my dad
when i was 13 i said what the hell's
tronsy really mean
he said it means trouble you were born
on a coldest day of my life
that's what he told me i'd rather have
him shot me right in the heart
weird how would you describe your
childhood
i didn't have one
pretty much
but anyway the old man took me to the um
clark street a little bitty house
and then he bought a two-story house
with three bedrooms
on charlotte street that's what like the
elm street that's when the nightmare
started
i mean he raped my mom beat her and beat
us and
boxed a refrigerator but he couldn't get
in
go to work for two weeks come back two
weeks later
my poor mom and just struggle and get
food and penis and [ __ ]
i told him when i was younger when i get
old enough i'm going to kick your ass
what you're doing
mom and all this i was 15 i put a
lick on his ass he never forgot
but then that i made an enemy out of my
own dad somehow
and how far are you in school
i'm two weeks in high school but i went
through a lot of vocational schools
i mean at 15 when i went to the
reformatory the first time
i i worked for the taylor shop
i told i was my mother you knew the guy
real good they were drinking buddies
my mother was alcoholic my dad didn't
drink
but anyway my mother told me to go in
and tell him about me
i was like what because you can fix
anything
and i can't imagine i did my first
go-kart
when i was 11. um i couldn't get to go
over 45
so i called my uncle porky and jerry
hendrickson
said how come i can't get this we go
over 45 miles an hour i can't outrun the
cops
he said i'll come over and i'll pick up
a
gear box for you i said well you need a
gearbox
he says like shifting a car
sticker i didn't understand too much
about that but
he went and got it so we had both wheels
to drive and 95 miles an hour the cops
clocked
me i had to hit all the time
my dad they went to my dad my dad told
them where i was here that
and they took my go-kart away
and they will just cut my throat at that
point
because there wasn't nothing really good
to live for
[Music]
back then and in 61
they poisoned all of us i mean my
brothers almost
all died told me and poisoning
my mother didn't do it on purpose my dad
would come home and see
like a hamburger in the sink falling out
he'd throw it back in the freezer he did
that
all the time and they thought my mom
and him plan to kill us
but i was the one that didn't think
they were gonna kill because i didn't
get sick that two weeks after
they were all in the hospital so i
figured they'd poison me
afterwards because i was uh francis's
favorite that's the oldest son
so i'm the oldest castilian alive right
now
how do you know i'm 71.
i was born january 28th actually in 1949
but my dad
went and had a birth sleep he made it
for me in 1955
from his doctor in hortonville wisconsin
give him fifty dollars
he couldn't remember when i was born it
was 49.50 so he put down 50.
january 28th he remembered but he didn't
remember what year
the only reason i know all that stuff is
because my grandmother on my mother's
side
the burn guyet she uh
she was a school teacher third grade
school teacher back then
and she told me all about names but i
don't know why i can remember
all that stuff and when i turned 55 i
lived on
owens and main street in a retired
elderly apartment complex there
i lived with marie of our name was
alberta walker
we called her marie uh
she was a controlled freak but she was
all for good to me
i mean she always made sure i had a
walk-in closet my own bedroom everything
and rides everywhere and scooters for
the casinos and stuff she made sure i
always had everything
i don't know why but she did
and i was pretty good hustler back then
but you had jobs throughout your life
all my life
what kind of jobs well tree trimming a
lot
i did mechanics i worked in junkyards
i work i worked at gulper's
paper place it's about the worst job in
appleton wisconsin
so that's where i grew up in appleton i
was born in hortonville
i'm 55 he brought me out of hortonville
and
appleton and put me in a public school
oh hey i couldn't get along with nobody
because i didn't know nothing
i didn't know about another kid
they put me in a special education they
take me from one school to another
school
then my mother would get all the
neighbors clothes and
some of them kids would pick on me like
that just be my shirt last year and [ __ ]
like that then the fighting started
in trouble all the time
and he called me tronzy because i was
trouble
you been married one time
i married you in 1973
a year after i got out of prison the
neatest person in the world
she bought me my purse horribly i i had
two triumphs in a bsa at 56.
all chopped up she said what do you want
for your birthday honey i said
a harley since you already got bikes
i said but they're not a harley i said
they're not race grinders but they're
not harley
so she went to the police station
i think it was in 74
in l.a and bought it from the police
department when they went from harley to
honda
now they're back to harley you know here
too
um honda is a a better bike to the
harley in a lot of ways
um not real stay together you can take a
road trip across country 100 times with
a honda
i hardly you gotta stop a hundred times
i don't wanna be able to fix it
and that's the way it was uh i
chopped it out it took me two weeks i
made an 18 over on it i used wide glide
tubes with a narrow glide frame
i put a 36 inch [ __ ] bar on i put
suicide on it
i stretched the old frame i couldn't
afford a jammer frame at the time
so i stretched the frame i was living in
san gabriel san dimas then
i bought a 99 000 house
on the government on the government's
land
for a 99-year lease i was only paying
like 275 a month
my wife went and got a job at a ice
cream place
in the uh courthouse so we'd always have
the rent no matter what
and i dealt with a lot of drugs
how was your marriage awesome
she took a madman and brought him down
the earth
yeah when i met her i was uncontrollable
breathing crazy as hell
you didn't want to sing too much to me
because i
[Music]
i just feel violent right now my eyes
are green right
a couple of months from now they'll be
blue again i have
bedroom blue eyes but when they're green
i'm extremely violent
um i mean i i beat up some men there
300 pounds and [ __ ] like that
how i don't know
it's just the way it was
how long did your marriage last um
about nine years she's been good about
47 years
your marriage ended because your wife
passed away yes
how was your day my seminar here
hit our 68 camaro she wanted to drive
that down i had big fat tires on the
back i had 327
in it i mean i had torsion bars on a
shift getting the transmission
i mean the baby would stand right up
pick right off the ground if you punch
your heart
enough and i just put these big tires on
and i told her i said
if you want to drive when we go on the
on-ramp
don't punch it she punches it
sits still seminars
that was really that was really
something i
never expected thought about anything
i still miss her after your marriage
were there other relationships
well took a long time after that i
pretty much stayed alone i was too
worried about um
another woman dying around me or
because of me or whatever and i wouldn't
made a hot rod for the streets
the car wouldn't have stood still
you know but anyway i'll tell you what
happened in four queens
i went to my favorite machine there was
a dark-haired chick sitting next to it
machine next to it i went to sit down
and say
i've been waiting for you for four
queens for queen's casino yeah
she said i've been waiting for you don i
said excuse me
do you you need to you need help or
something
she said no i've been waiting for you i
have something for you
i said you all right so
donnie thought i'd give me 130 a week
no matter what i had pocket money
but i wouldn't get troubles well
she hands me a hundred dollar bills five
dollars on a ten dollar bill
i'm looking at what's this about
she said somebody and you're way in your
past
asked me to do this for them
i'm sure you know who it is
i said what are you she said i'm a
psychic i own a psychic business here in
town
and all of a sudden her husband came up
her boyfriend
through a big guy and he said honey do
you need me to go to the atm machine get
more money for you or anything
she said no i think i got it all handled
pretty well
he said so you don't need me to do
anything you know
she said we gotta handle don't we don't
i guess i just can't understand
how she knew all so much
that uh donna somehow has been in
contact with her
she's been gone 47 years
and i've always been alone
because of it even when i got a
girlfriend i'm still alone
why i don't know i walk alone
that's a lot i damn gambling started for
you
at what age well i i came here in 73
with
my wife down and we read in a room over
at
flamingo i asked her do you want to go
downstairs to gamble with me she said no
i'm going to stop and read the book she
was well educated
so i couldn't read until i was 16 i
learned how myself how to read with a
dictionary bible
but anyway i said well i'm gonna go
downstairs
it was the old flamingo then the wooden
structure
the the casino part where all the tables
were
went way down in the ground
you know about six eight feet uh i went
down there and i only took 125 dollars
on it with me
she said you should i said no i said
that's plenty of money but i can't win
with 125
i don't want a gamble right so i went
down there
i watched for a while and my little
brother john
john was with me he came with us out
here
and he kept coming over and talking to
me and
he said why don't you just follow one of
them old
girls that are gambling there's a couple
of them i mean they were gambling
the real deal shaking the dice and doing
everything i'd pass to let her shake
she she knew what she was doing but
anything she bet on i couldn't bet the
kind of money she was dead
but i could bet on everything about
eight o'clock in the morning i had
eleven thousand dollars
and i don't think it caused any problems
except for
i went upstairs when my broom and
i threw the money on the other bit
and donna said to me who'd you rob i
said you just took all the fun out of
this
i said why did you say i robbed somebody
she's because that's your mo
from your past uh
i know she was right but
so what were your games gambling craps
21 mostly though i like this one
i went down to what they call that place
out there's a little desert
searchlight i went down there in that
i played 21 a lot of times that's where
i'd go and
her laughing and um
i know donald moffat and all these kids
anybody
and i bring a lot of money i mean a lot
of my
she said you're really good i just paid
a count cards but back then
only thing i passed in school was math
so i could count cards
alone they only had one deck in most
places you know
instead of two or three decks when i
started using feed decks they've messed
everybody up
i can't count three decks it just ain't
gonna happen
yeah i made a lot of money 21 table and
craps
but craps i just followed somebody that
knew what they were doing
i mean you could stand back and observe
your surroundings and bring yourself to
a certain
mood and you can follow somebody around
the exact same thing well i'm out of
them even knowing you're doing it
but you enjoyed gambling it was you
enjoyed winning and losing both or just
hey i don't mind losing but the whole
thing is
i'd rather win but you don't go into the
casino
with the idea that you're going to win
i mean a lot of people say i'm going to
win tonight good luck i hope so you know
but the truth is gambling
is more like uh relaxation if you wanted
to be
but most people get uptight and angry
and pissed off because they lost money
hell i lost 1800 till 9 1500
i mean i should have some money i kept
twenty thousand dollars in a shoebox and
my closet over on
owens i mean and uh my girlfriend you
say
why are you keeping the shoebox that's
what i always did
brad back but i lost ten thousand
dollars i still had ten thousand dollars
to come back
but once you lose it all
uh it's hard to
[Music]
to gamble against them you got to have
some kind of odds
some kind of lead way you know
so you've been gambling for how many
years uh since 73.
are you still you're still gambling now
or no i was out yesterday
i was out this morning yesterday i went
out with
20 bucks i made 203 dollars
and then i gave my girlfriend some money
she lost it all so i
i've stuck 20 in the machine i said sit
down and play this with me
she had 600 she gave me 100.
yeah i believe that so you're playing
slot machines as well
yeah i i didn't i didn't do that until
about
god it was at the time i was gone
i always played out on the tables
because slot machines that's where the
casinos get all their money
the cables are totally different and the
best paid thing is
uh roulette you know a lot of people
don't know how to play with that
all you do is throw a twenty dollar bill
in
four spots you know like eight five
seven
six whatever you know a group here that
everywhere
you usually come out but
it's the biggest odds twenty twenty
dollars to a dollar
you know but i like i like
21 i like crabs
crap's the exciting game it's all about
the hype and who's showing the dice and
all this and that
you're addicted to gambling
and probably
so today you're you're living homeless
on the streets here in las vegas
yes how long have you been homeless i
think about
a little over two years and i guess i
lost my motorhome a little over two
years ago
and then after that i've been in a
apartment over on
bambino uh 409 van buren
westby apartment one
well my little girlfriend she was only
you know
early for 30.
our life wasn't exciting enough having
an apartment
it's just fun to live on the streets
so we went and lived on the streets
and i've been there ever since
what would you blame gambling for why
you're in the situation you're in today
no i i believe donny myself
i wouldn't blame gambling i think
gambling is
a home wrecker some people can't handle
some people can't
i go out there and lose every dollar i
have
and not this about it i said damn why'd
i do that
but everybody else be crying and whine
what am i gonna do
would you would you say you had a good
life looking back at your
absolutely very interesting life
some of it was pretty shaky i remember
when i used to be scared when i was
right young
[Music]
scared what i don't know i think about
else
adults were always my biggest problem
i grew up i was a man of 15 years old
and
now i'm a boy do you understand that
scary from that um
i think of down every day i have
always
i know she's close to me somewhere
that's like really made me pretty i was
freaking
telling me all that stuff but she gave
me the 130
she says does this mean something to you
so that's what diamond gave me every
week 130
for pocket money but i just like those
all the casinos reno i mean
everywhere i mean i've sold
my vans my cars before i could go gamble
pawn shops oh yeah pawn shops got my
bluetooth right now my watch i got a
bitching watch from the 70s
about from the 90s and i got
not the latest bluetooth the one before
this last one i come out
it's ten times better than the new one i
mean a kick
i got in there i just got out
my other bluetooth last month and
i got some elsa i got paint guns in
there you know
things you shoot at each other all kinds
of stuff
i sold a
diamond ring i had forever i had like 29
diamonds in it
just like go get them i'm out to the
railroad station
lost my ass
but i call it picking up sticks
do you lose everything what do you do
you don't sit there with your head
hanging down and whining
you go pick up sticks now they'll put
your life back together
all right don well thank you so much for
sharing your story
and i wish you the best of luck out
there it was a pleasure
uh talking to you by the way you are a
different kind of a man than most
a lot a lot of people out here they
don't have time to talk to nobody
their lives are too congested i guess
after a while when you get into a
comfortable zone
what the hell as long as you get showers
clean clothes
i like doing laundry i like washing
dishes
and i love chasing women you know
thank you very much you're welcome sir
my pleasure by the way
you're pretty you're a pretty neat man